well now the Scottish Labour Party could
be allowed to design its own policies
according to a report in the sunday
times newspaper this morning the party
was almost totally wiped out of course
north of the border back in the May
general election losing all but one of
its MPs in Scotland when our scottish
labour has a new leader of course his
promise to renew the party kezia dugdale
joins me now a very good morning to so
it's going to be an autonomous Scottish
Labour Party is it yes and this is an
essential thing that we've got to do in
Scotland to transform our party to get
it fit for the future to regain the
trust of voters across Scotland that
we've lost so badly over the past few
months now I won the Scottish Labour
leadership contest with a tremendous
mandate seventy two percent of the vote
to do exactly this to lead an autonomous
Scottish Labour Party where decisions
about our policies who stands for us in
the direction of her party i made in
scotland and that's what people the
length and the breadth of the country
want to see but of course one of the big
reasons you'll have heard it more than I
you know it more than hire one of the
big reasons it seems that many many
voters deserted Scottish Labour was the
campaigning during the course of the
independence referendum that you stood
all your leader you're then leader stood
for square alongside the views of all
the other parties within the United
Kingdom that you represented that your
body represented that the Westminster
bubble well there's no doubt that
standing side by side with the Tory side
a damaging effect in the Scottish Labour
Party but being in mind there were
people of all parties are none involved
in the campaign for yes and no during
the referendum but that's a debate
that's in the past well I'm in the
business of talking about is Scotland's
future meeting the hopes and aspirations
of voters across the country and in
order to do that we have to be able to
make policy decisions in Scotland in the
Scottish interest now what I would say
to the derma is I hope very much that
this is the starting gun of a debate
across the whole of the Labour Party
across the whole of the UK about we're
paralyzed and hope you organized labor
people and labour values agency in
effect of federal Labor Party Frank
fields just been on veteran librarian
people's talking about just that that
the nations and regions should in effect
have their own labor parties I would
support a more federal solution for the
organization of the Labour Party
undoubtedly I think that's the direction
that we need to go in the co Scottish
Labour Party was
party of devolution but the one mistake
we made was not to devolve the party
itself knows the time to do that so I
want to lead a more autonomous party
where decisions around her policies are
made in scotland not because of some
theoretical debate about how the Liberal
Party should form its own structures but
because I want to represent the views of
people across the country and print
Scotland fest in that regard people are
going to be sitting at home listening to
this same well give us some specifics I
mean it's okay it's pretty harder than
Homer to define what papers policies are
as a uk-based party in many areas but
how would you differ from the Corbin
leadership well I'm going into the
Scottish Labour Party conference next
weekend with a strong focus on tackling
inequality I came into politics to
tackle education they will hold on you
know we've heard patties one thing your
listeners don't hear very often is a
proper critique of what's happening in
Scotland and under the SNP so we've had
eight years of SNP government and we now
have 6,000 kids across the country
leaving school unable to read properly
you know one in four people in the
newest hospital in Scotland have to make
more than four hours in A&E department
to be seen our public services are in a
mess and they aren't getting the
scrutiny that they need because there
isn't a strong enough opposition in
place to take on those arguments this is
very much a part of that debate making
sure the Scottish Labour Party is fit
for the future what about this specific
issue of tax credits it's unclear and
the SNB been asked if and when it gets
more fiscal autonomy whether it would
mitigate the effect of cuts to tax
credits that's explicit than is it from
Scottish Labour that that you would make
sure that Scottish people who receive
tax credits would not be affected you're
right that the SNP's positions on
clearing this up here hair joints when
you see one thing in Angus Robertson see
another I'm going to wait until next
weekend Tilly out just exactly my policy
position on tax credits if you don't
mind I'm as much they would love to give
you a bond that come on I'm just asking
miss mrs. a specific question if you win
power it's a mighty piggy if of course
in the Scottish elections would you make
sure that Scottish voters are not
affected by cuts to their tax credit
well we will find out very soon about
the parish that the Scottish Parliament
will get from the Scotland bill and the
degree to which we will be able to
mitigate things like that in the
Scottish Parliament isn't one hundred
percent clear yet we will get clarity
soon I tell you one thing though I'm
absolutely opposed to what George
Osborne is trying to do here it's very
clear that an average families across
Scotland and you know we're talking
about two hundred thousand families here
could lose up to 1,300 pounds of their
income now this is a government that
purports to represent working people
this is an attack on working people it's
a tack on decent work it's an attack on
people who just want to go out both to
work and build a better lives for
themselves so there's no doubt that the
Labour Party stands united in opposition
to these tax cuts but I mean you've got
to argue you've got to tell people what
is different from the Westminster Labour
Party I haven't really heard anything
that I haven't heard from many many of
the the contenders who were fighting
that leadership election some of them
actually lost it of course but
particularly Jeremy Corbyn you're not
saying anything different as far as I
can discern jeremy corbyn and i agree on
many things of course we do were in the
same political party leader however
there are issues in which in Scotland we
need to take a different position to
develop our policies in our own
direction which are well area let's talk
about welfare reform for example we will
soon have more perigean tax and welfare
reform in Scotland I want to use those
powers to tackle educational inequality
and the types of policies that I'll come
up with in Scotland might not suit other
parts the United Kingdom that's why it's
important to have an autonomous Scottish
Labour Party where we can design
policies that fit the Scottish interest
but take you back to that earlier point
Dermot this isn't just about Scotland
this is about whether the Labour Party
itself is fit for the big ideas the big
issues of the future so my appeal is to
people across the UK labour party see
this is the start of a debate that you
have a big part in can we have more
Paris on wheels is there a debate now
about how the Labour Party organizes
itself in the big cities and regions
you've heard jaunt registries this over
the weekend as well what I'm saying to
people is learn the mistakes of Scottish
Labour don't repeat them there's a
chance here to reform an innovator our
party is organized and how it is
structured if we get it right are quite
a bit a much stronger and fitter
position for I mean what is your
experience of the attitude towards
scottish labour at the moment since the
election of jeremy corbyn isn't your
Prada it was getting more popular that
some Scottish photos actually quite like
what Jeremy Corbyn is saying of course
he's moved the party to the left and it
was said that the SNP aired out left
did the Labor Party under its previous
leadership but now jeremy corbyn's more
in tune perhaps this is the solution to
old problems actually since both myself
and Jeremy have been elected the
Scottish Labour Party membership is
growing number of members and supporters
no stands over 30,000 that's as high as
it's been since 1997 there are multitude
of reasons for that but your point about
Jeremy Corbyn being more or less wing of
the SMP or bluntly that's not difficult
because that accepts the premise that
the SNP are a left-wing party I can't
point to a single progressive policy
that they stand for not a single policy
that redistributes wealth from the
richest to the purest for example they
have to tax policies which really
involve cutting business taxes whether
that be corporation tax which has been a
long-standing position of the SNP or the
more recent policy they've picked
forward around giving local government
the parative cut business trees not to
change the barriers or to let put them
up to cuts business rates that's not the
actions of a progressive left-wing party
and the other point to the memberid irma
is you know you're forgetting their the
referendum and the impact that that had
done scotland it wasn't about left or
right was about yes or a No I do hope
though that those arguments are in the
past it was an autonomous Scottish
Labour Party will be fit for the future
as well is it that they're very good to
see thank you very much indeed the
leader of Scottish Labour there